chuckle my wife told me that she sees I
am much more direct and less cordial
than I used to be I feel I've pushed too
much into getting after it and it makes
those around me feel like I've changed
to someone else yeah we have to be
really careful yes right yes because
being more direct and less cordial is
definitely not getting after it in fact
it's the opposite if you are getting
after it in a correct manner your wife
should be completely stoked you know
because you're gonna have more time for
her cuz you're gonna be doing time
management properly mm-hmm you're gonna
have you're gonna be doing better at
work which means you're gonna be getting
promoted or whatever getting paid more
or you know getting job stability or
whatever something like that
you're gonna be healthier because your
your work and how you're gonna be
stronger because you're working out
you're gonna be more organized with
things and you're gonna be more
thoughtful about building that's what
I'm getting after is you like your your
relationship should be improving yes not
this and this is one of those this is
one of Echo Charles's favorite things to
talk about her sexually something that
you've just brought up a bunch of times
on the podcast which is when someone
says no that's just how I am like oh I'm
just gonna tell you the truth because
that's just how I am just making an
excuse for being a jerk coming out of
the gate which is not good so if that's
what you're doing with your wife you
know what
I'm just gonna get after it hey this
tuna casserole sucks I'm just telling
you what it is that's how I roll like no
you're actually rolling in the wrong
direction when you're getting after it
in a good way your wife will be stoked I
was getting interviewed the other day
and I realized this so I've written
eight books the eighth one comes out in
January of 2020 it's a lot of writing
I wrote 90% of the words in those books
while my family was asleep then it made
almost no impact on the family mm-hmm
I'm writing these books editing is a
little bit different cuz there's a
timeline on editing so sometimes my
family would be awake while editing and
I had to get stuff turned back in and
it's a pain but that's like a takes a
week right but the other 90% of getting
after it was done while my family is
asleep
if you contrary are getting after it at
the expense of your family and friends
that's not that's actually being selfish
mmm so that's one part okay so maybe you
need to check yourself there and make
sure that you've got your priorities in
order there is a chance however that
your friends don't like seeing you start
to get some altitude right start to be
more successful start to lead a better
life there's all kinds of groups of
people that will just drag you back down
they don't want to see you in yeah
that's sort of I I don't know is that
the fundamental kind of baseline human
instinct I don't want to see you in if
there is an element of it too I would
not be surprised you put it that way but
I don't know there's at least a
non-trivial part of the prop ulation
population that does not want to see you
win yeah there's at least a percentage
whatever that percentage is of the
people that you know that does not want
to see you in they would rather see you
fail they would rather and maybe fails
not the word but they would at least
rather have you stay with them yeah yeah
that makes sense only so there's a
chance that that's going on is there a
chance that that's going on with your
wife
hopefully not that's a slim chance
because if you think about it your
success her success is predicated on
your success I mean you are bound to
each other both each of your success is
predicated on each other's success so do
I want my wife to be successful oh yeah
because I that's my wife
mm-hm and she's looking at me going yes
go be successful the more successful I
am the more successful she is so there's
a there's most likely your your wife in
my opinion would be supportive of your
efforts unless you're just getting out
of control there's a chance I guess that
a wife could see you know someone change
and you know that's not the person that
I married right
but hold on the person that you married
was lazy and I'm over here getting after
it the person that you married was
making X amount of money now I'm making
a lot more than that the person that you
married wasn't in good physical shape
I'm in good physical shape hmm most of
the time the wife would say cool yeah
I'm getting a better deal now
occasionally I think you would get a
spouse I guess could be the male or the
female could happen on either side that
goes oh you want to work hard and I'm
gonna really not looking to do that I
was comfortable right I was comfortable
that's it yeah I'm comfortable I don't
want you getting all crazy I'm over here
being comfortable so that could happen
hmm I think that's unlikely I think
what's most likely is you are focused on
yourself a little bit too much check
yourself for that
that should be the first person you look
at you yeah that's true huh cuz like it
is actually kind of common where husband
wife whichever the scenario is where one
let's say let's say two people they get
married whatever years down the road one
of the people in the couple the
relationship
improves themself a lot to lose a bunch
of weight they're they're literally by
their own standard they were not very
attractive when they got married but now
this is 10 years later whatever they
become straight-up attractive now making
more money more people want to hang out
with them cuz they're nicer like all
this stuff straight up across the board
improvement mm-hmm meanwhile the other
person in the relationship didn't do
that still married still all good no
infidelity nothing like that still
married but that person who didn't
improve themselves will feel like they
got phased out or kind of like like the
person might want to upgrade or
something like that you know so it's
like it's impossible they try and drag
the person back down yeah because you
need to be back here I need to be feel
sick
now I'm this husband and now my wife's
hi I'm not used to a hot life because
when we got married you weren't that hot
mmm I loved you for you and you know all
this stuff and you know what they say or
whatever and um and now you're know you
know how to know them thinking cliche
movie thing but anyway the the wife's
like all good-looking now people were
like people at the store like complement
here and all this stuff and the guy's
not used to it and now in his mind a
little thing develops or it's like oh oh
like I'm not good enough now for this
hot girl I'm gonna buy her some Cheetos
yeah bring her back down so like at
least have some manage you know
manageable amount of control this person
that's you know that's not an uncommon
thing in that specific scenario I guess
that scenario is not very common though
it's not a very common scenario and then
it would have to be doubly uncommon for
someone to actually want to drag them
back down I have to throw it out there
though because it is a possibility yeah
but for this particular question I don't
think so only because this little
indicator right here my wife told me
that she sees I am much more direct and
usually much more direct means
insensitive in my experience wives don't
do good generally speaking with
insensitivity less cordial that's
another one in my opinion in my
experience because I'm married yeah
metalcore do you learn things I'm gonna
give you an example something I learned
about my wife if my if my wife if it
isn't on the schedule it's about enough
to make my wife get mad right so in
other words if I said hey I'm going away
for one a month from now I'm going away
for six months on a work trip I'll be
back when I'm done with those six months
and when I'm gone and you're not gonna
be able to hear from you at all she'd be
like okay got it when do you leave and
I'd say well I'm leaving whatever yeah
September 1st and she'd go okay she
wouldn't be even remotely upset just be
good to go yeah if it was Friday night
and I came home and said
oh I'm I didn't tell you or Saturn I
said I didn't tell you but I'm going
over to echos to watch the UFC there's a
decent chance that she's mad about that
because she had in her mind that we were
gonna eat whatever yeah we were going
out for dinner or whatever but I didn't
I didn't give the pre-planned yeah
situation what if she didn't make a plan
for that it was just sort of maybe we
could do that it's it's no it's not on
her it's on me yes on me for not
informing her of what was going on cuz
it doesn't really matter all she knew is
that I was coming home yeah and I was
gonna be around and that was what was
happening yeah because it was anything
that is not put you know what's really
funny this is again with my wife and
this is this is where it became evident
to me even if it's something that is
positive for my wife if I don't give her
pre-planning cycle on on what's gonna
happen so in other words if I was flying
home and I'd been are gone for a week
and I just you know got home and busted
through the door and said hey I'm on a
tail end of a 72-hour fast I'm starving
I'm taking you out and I made
reservations for this really nice dinner
let me go get some you know a $200 steak
right now there's a chance but the the
the the the percentage should be 100%
she's stoked right that should be the
percentage however with my wife there's
a twenty to thirty percent chance that
she says you know I was gonna take you
know I was gonna take our daughter to
you know the raffle I don't know to play
bingo and like that is enough and and
and I what I don't do is I say oh cool
you know what we'll go tomorrow
what I don't do is trying to impose it
so what you're saying is like lack of
being cordial what I'm saying is it's
not just like that's one example of me
not being cordial so I don't I try not
to I guess I guess I guess to sum it up
my wife doesn't really like
surprises yeah right she likes to have a
plan she likes to know what's happening
and then she'll execute the plan so
that's what you got to be careful of you
witch got to be well not not what you
got be careful if that is one example of
how these little things they don't make
sense it doesn't make sense that some
that my wife wouldn't be super stoked to
go out to a awesome steak house yeah
that doesn't make sense to anymore well
you know that's a superficial thing and
let me tell you something else that
makes it a little bit tricky is I'm
super insensitive to like changing plans
like people change plans that we have
like whatever it's no fit it's literally
no factor yeah oh wait oh yeah we've
been planning to do this for six months
someone's like I can't do it I'm like
okay cool yeah you don't mean it's it
means nothing to me
when things change it means nothing
that's I it has no impact on me I have
no emotional reaction to someone saying
hey this we can't do this now and I'm
like okay cool I'm gonna do something
else
yeah so I'm at the other end of the
spectrum yeah which means it took me a
little while to figure out that oh this
makes you mad yeah got it
you know yeah and it's probably probably
something like one level like under the
surface - it's not like hey I had this
good you know the raffle was was planned
in my head and that raffle is important
the raffle is not important neither's
the dinner it's like that part of it on
that level is not important it's one
level deeper it's the fact that I had to
sit my head you didn't tell me this
other thing and now like what I had in
my head really means nothing yeah so
it's kind of that here's another funny
thing about my wife is she's so into the
planning thing that if I planned
something it has way more value to her
so in other words if I say hey when I
get back this Friday mm-hmm I'm gonna do
a fast and I'm gonna be super hungry I'm
gonna make reservations for this Friday
right and we can go out and get an
awesome steak you know tomahawk rib eye
and like the fact that it was
pre-planned like I've done this before
we're after taking her and I've gotten
reservations and she'll be like did you
make reservations and I'll say yes I
yeah I did and I can see like a little
smile like I care a little bit more that
I made those reservations like that's
pretty what what the spontaneity thing
no does no no no points for spontaneity
no zero zero points respond any only
points for pre-planned fires you know
why why did it's thoughtful yeah yeah
exactly
yes yes yeah that's great that's good
that's good that's an interesting
quality right there and I guess my point
in saying this this these things mmm is
that everyone has these little
personality traits people you work with
people your your spouse your children
they have these things and if you figure
out what those things are you can
actually utilize them to your advantage
and you can bypass things that will be
problematic and something that you've
said to is you say oh you do this stuff
to me meaning Jaakko does you I do some
like leadership trick to you you know
that I'm doing it yeah but it's still
like it works and it still makes you
feel the way that you know it's supposed
to make you feel and that's my point
like my wife will listen to this
yeah and it's and then I'll make
reservations and she'll still be here
even though that she knows that I'm
doing it just because I know that it's
gonna be something that makes her happy
yeah yeah so just because you reveal
like hey I know this is what you're like
or even whether you reveal it or not
doesn't matter when someone has that
characteristic then you can utilize that
characteristic right oh that's not the
best sounding word to talk about like
manipulating my wife's emotions yeah but
what I want to do is manipulate her
emotions to make her feel happy about
something the right not necessarily a
bad thing it's a good thing so be
cognizant when you're dealing with other
human
beings look for these things you see
these things if you take a step back if
you don't take a step back you'll never
see them if you can't detach when you
tell your wife something and you you you
see that it makes her mad if you can't
detach if you talking to an employee and
you see that they're getting frustrated
and you can't detach to try and figure
out what that is you're not gonna make
any real progress
so yeah the direct thing we like to be
when people are direct to us and makes
things easier for us you know but does
lose weightweight who's the way I don't
retire who ever people who nice because
here's the deal man direct is a very a
very blunt force tool and not many
people wield it well and not many people
receive it well yeah so if you're one of
these people is that you all just look
to be direct right that's not good
and very seldom do you end up in
situations where you can just be direct
with people you have to have real strong
built relationships with people where
you can just be that blunt and direct
with them now there are methodologies
where you can be direct without being
direct mmm you know you can say things
that are hey this is what we need to get
done right now you can take an edge off
of it
yeah you can and the way you usually do
that is by taking your ownership of what
it is you're trying to make happen so
what I don't say is like echo you need
to get this thing edited tonight Yeah
right I don't do that I might say hey is
there any chance we could get this thing
edited tonight because if we don't we're
gonna have a gap in releases which by
the way we haven't had and that's kind
of a thing yeah you see even you just
kind of know that it's a thing it is
isn't it we're there and all of a sudden
you want to edit that thing not because
I told you do because you want to keep
the gaps from be opening up sure so I
was I was directly telling you but I was
in direct
so there's ways to do it but you've got
to be careful with direct direct it
takes a long time to to hone the scalpel
of directs to where it just gets where
you want to cut and it doesn't leave any
collateral damage not many people are
good at it
yeah very few people are good at it next
question
Junko and you know that makes people mad
what does the will you say listen you
can't just be you can't just you can't
just throw to people people people want
to say like there's the book there's a
book called radical frankness or
something like that that's not the name
of the book but it's something like that
it's like hey we just gonna tell the
total radical transparency or something
like that and it's like we're just gonna
tell the truth all the time
and we we can get there but man it is
work yeah and it's not even work that
has to be that that necessarily is the
best use Network yeah so yeah I just
know I just know I hear people all the
time well you know and people that's
what people want me to say I'll go and
work with a company look you know what
we really need help us we just need to
really learn to be direct with each
other yeah and what what they really
should be saying is what we need to do
is we need to learn to communicate with
each other be open about what issues we
have how to solve those problems and be
more tactful in our discussions so that
people are receptive yeah cuz think
about what I just said
if it's not just about me being direct
the more important the only way that I
can be direct is if I have set you up in
such a way that you or I've built you in
such a way that you're receptive to my
directness because me being direct
without you being receptive it doesn't
work and so often that's what I see I
hey I'm direct but but you're not
receptive it's it's game over yeah so
even if I'm direct I'm only 50% of the
solution because you have to be
receptive yeah what's easier when I when
I go indirect I become 90% of the
solution because I'm gonna get it into
your brain without resistance yeah
so I it's an easier it's easier up front
of me I'll just be direct yeah that's
easy up front because I just say echo
you need to get this stuff edited now
that's direct mm-hmm
one of the chances of you being
receptive to that 50% yeah you know
whereas if I well let me rephrase that
in order for this to be effective you
have to be receptive to it yeah
so I only have 50% of the solution you
have the other 50% whereas if I say like
I said before you know hey echo we is
there any chance we could get this done
tonight because here's what's at stake
in it and I go indirect and I make that
idea and make your answer you're gonna
give me the answer I want I know it can
be edited tonight right I know that it
makes sense and so I'm gonna you're
actually gonna tell me yeah I'm putting
it in to you I'm giving you all you have
to do is just tell me and now I'm the
one that's receptive yes we can't oh
that's great
that's great I'm glad so that's
something very important to talk about
if you want to talk about learning to be
direct with each other what you really
have to learn is how to be receptive to
directness that's the that's the long
pole in the tent and that's what
organizations are missing out on being
direct as easy yeah being direct is the
easiest thing in the world you tell
people what you think that's easy yeah
what's hard is setting the other person
up developing relationship so that
they're receptive to what you're saying
yeah be careful you just play football
back in the day and mmm this new
quarterback came in a few what's weird
is I forget his name I'm just drawing a
blank right now but new young guy tall
and he had a gun if you're a quarterback
and you have a gun
it's impressive you know yeah for sure
means you throw far and fast here's the
thing though especially when you're new
you know and you have a gun you're
you're gonna show that gun you know
you're gonna be like when you're playing
you know when you're warming up before
practice and stuff like that you're
throwing anything throwing it heart so
this guy was throwing it hard at me I
was a receiver and we're just it was
just standing and we were just standing
there I wasn't running around so he's
throwing it and it's hurting my hand to
the point where I couldn't catch some of
them because they were coming just too
fast for you know for that distance or
whatever and he's sure I was impressed
with this guy's gun but he won we'd
wanna run routes and stuff he'd still
kind of do that I guess maybe to impress
the coaches you know he's a young guy or
whatever and here's the thing like
people would miss his balls they
wouldn't catch them because they're
coming too hard they're hurting your
hands they're messing you up you know so
it makes you really hard good I get it
it's great practice for the receivers
totally is but as far as to effectively
land a pass you know to complete a pass
right doesn't work like this and we had
this other quarter longnecker let me
just stop you because you may have just
made like the best analogies ever made
on this podcast that is it cool if that
if you can throw that thing direct but
if you're throwing it too hard and the
person's not ready to receive it right
not even not even to mention that you
might not be ready drew you might be
looking the other direction but it hits
you in the back of the head you know
what good is that direct comment it's
zero good it's not good
hurting your hands when you've tried it
receive it it hurts you yeah and you
don't want to hear anymore you want
anymore to be thrown at you
nope okay proceed as opposed to this
other quarterback who came in from
Stanford but your hard work is paying
off that's so this other quarterback
Keinath that quarterback and make it
anywhere did he make the NFL he did not
make it to that I think oh so so the
quarterback came in his name's Tim Kerry
came from links down for anything and he
came in he was the at Penn of the
opposite actually not the opposite cuz
he had a guy he could throw far and
suffer but the way he threw it was like
it was like the perfect pass like every
distance had a different velocity on it
you know it was like that kind where the
next if he would modulated
so well he modulated so well we're
likely did the volume for those chassés
reckless oh yeah everything and for them
to get better he would have to
physically walk in and put it in your
hand it was like that good when he'd
come you know and when you have them
side by side oh man I want that direct
die what the finesse guy you know but he
did have a capability oh thank you to
the NFL um I maybe I forget he left
Stanford to come to your college um I
forget why but I think we're good it was
a whole thing there was a few Stanford
guys that came yeah that's interesting
yeah a few guys from Stanford that came
two years ago they didn't you H yeah it
was doing it I want to say when we
changed coaching staffs there might have
been some Scouts connections maybe like
some relationships that were already
there even some of the coaches I think
came from that area I don't know I
forget that was a long time ago but
nonetheless yeah that's a wait check out
sure so there you go